it's nearly Christmas time yes time and
people are getting into the party season
right so what we've done is we've set up
a bit of a share based shindig out the
back and I don't mind telling you the
word is it has totally gone off it's
really it's awful it's mad
so look a look at our part god bless
well look they're not outside no in
fairness that all the party the party
requires some music so hello crazy
people hello
so what we're going to do everyone we're
going to give you some share music to
dance to
well okay one the Red Bulls kicking in
but we're gonna do is we're gonna turn
down the sound yes so by watching them
dance yes we will try to guess what
share track they're dancing to okay hey
gay it's been a Christmas fun right turn
down the sound and a spin the first disc
prepared us back to be what do you think
shoot shoot you think shoot shoot shoot
shoot song okay let's bring up the track
[Music]
flaming the dance of the gods of the
terrible
how could have expected to guess these
songs
okay so ask it another day skip me go I
think they're gonna do the same dancing
did you have a song in Pulp Fiction
no oh baby this is the cheap cheap song
let's see is it a chip chip song
[Applause]
one more okay I wasn't the super saw was
it
[Applause]
let's do the sound up
senior mother it's such a large backlog
there's been so many I did I sing that
music what do we got these guys come on
they're all doing the same dance I
haven't seen the different dance this is
more arm-based but the green keeps
grabbing her throat yeah she believes in
life after love
[Applause]
[Music]
bye-bye you useless Bunch
you